alors agraire on retrouve tout de suite
franck mais l'esprit bonjour francs vous
avez pu rencontrer ce matin des proches
de john atta que vous ont-ils dit oui
bonjour jérémy effectivement à
stupéfaction partout dans la population
évidemment aujourd'hui mais aussi auprès
des proches de john attah naval y
compris les sportifs à vous savez on
parlait d'alexia la joggeuse alors le
monde du sport de la course à pied est
particulièrement traumatisée suite à la
cesa veut on attendra dans quelques
instants
le président du club sportif local mais
avant on voit aussi entendre le patron
de johnatan d'aval le patron que nous
avons rencontré ce matin et qui lui un
petit peu déstabilisé imaginez seulement
14 jours après la disparition
d'alexandre aval les enquêteurs sont
venus saisir le véhicule professionnel
de johnatan laval pour les
investigations sur ces véhicules
une saisie en totale contradiction avec
le rendez vous prévu le matin même de la
disparition d'alexia de johnatan avec
son patron une entrevue qui s'était
passé le plus normalement du monde
écoutez comment dire que je leur ai dit
de quelqu'un qui était souriant présenté
n'était pas à 100 de fermière johnatan
on l'a eue à côté de nous tout le temps
on prend tout en compte quand on a fait
la course quand on a fait quand on a
remis un bouquet de fleurs devant le pmu
qui déchire il était lent et c'est vrai
que les gens qui se sont sentis trompés
après voilà il trompé et trahi moi
personnellement qui est toujours défendu
je vous le dis je vous le redis je ne
croyais pas à cette seconde s'est jamais
passé dans ma tête jamais ce matin au
bar tenu par les parents dans l'excès
d'avaaz le silence régnait
oui au beau milieu des clients pardon et
du côté des parents aussi bien
évidemment